we are ended with a Wesley so Wesley I'm
going to ask you a similar question to
what I asked Sam you came back from
Berlin you did have a match in the
finals against Sam Shanklin you won that
yeah how do you feel that impacts this
particular match
uh well it doesn't really
change too many things the time
controller is very different I mean I'm
very happy to win the tournament in
Berlin the Armageddon series but at the
same time
Diamond control was very fast and the
game's a very short round they play the
games mini match and I only played eight
games in total so it's not a big deal I
mean it's
um my main focus is classical chess
although I don't seem to be doing well
but in this day and age you kind of need
to be good at all time controls so it's
nice that I can do well here and there
and that's very surprising to me because
you did so well in the global Chess
Championship you won that you just won
in Berlin as well it does feel like you
feel very comfortable in Rapid and Blitz
setups yeah seems to be the case uh
after the pandemic I've been practicing
a lot online I've been trying a lot of
different mouths
so the mechanics also are very important
right yeah it's very different playing
over the board than playing online
actually in Berlin I was sparring with
some other players there over the board
just because
playing on computer and a tablet it's
very very different and I've been
playing a lot online but
um
yeah at the same time my results in the
classical been fairly a bit
disappointing so for my reading right
now is around 27 60. I've been trying
for a couple years trying to get it up
to like in the 780 2790 but
I'm struggling a little bit so I'm
working on stuff and trying to improve
uh it's I'm very grateful that St Louis
is putting tournaments like here in the
American Cup we have eight of the best
players in the country
then we have grand Chester coming up in
Romania so I'm very excited for that
speaking of this match on tomorrow's
game with the black pieces what is your
strategy for that one are you going to
try to neutralize are you going to take
more risks with the black pieces what is
the strategy well I probably should take
them
could be listening but I you know just
uh in a two game mini match you can't
really afford to make too many mistakes
so I just want to
give my best you know and see where it
leads try to play the best moves uh
today he surprised me in the opening I
thought he would lead the Sicilian like
he was playing in the Berlin but uh
Sam's very unpredictable
and he knows a lot like I've never seen
this move
on the eighth move Bishop A7 before
yeah so I mean white Black Ops 3 other
main moves but Rook B8 Bishop G4 yeah
he played Bishop A7 and it looks a
little bit dubious but at the same time
I
didn't really know exactly what the best
ways to play without risking too much
um
and you were also spending a lot of time
in the opening phase but also in the
middle game phase he was building up
quite a substantial time Advantage did
you feel any pressure coming from that
yeah for sure that's why in the end I
was you know trying to play the most
logical moves uh
because one thing to note here is that
you don't get an extra time after move
40. so it's very very different
um the but at the same time in the
beginning you want to spend as much time
make sure not to make too many mistakes
not to make a blunder
by in the end I was speeding up but it
was definitely a struggling in terms of
time it affected from my decisions later
on so that's one thing that could be
improved upon that at the same time I'm
a bit surprised that some
was playing very very quickly today so
maybe he didn't have to
uh he didn't have to find too many moves
uh over the board because like Bishop E6
is simple
and also mostly moves like group B5
wasn't and Sam uh described you as one
of the toughest players to beat in this
tournament how would you describe Sam
yeah well that's very kind of him to say
I honestly don't think so but um
but I mean some is uh is a fighter uh
he's a very hard working fellow you know
he's written several books back about
his most recent book in quality chess uh
I'm very impressed by his determination
by the fact that he always bounces back
I think his results could be very
unpredictable and his player sometimes
could be uh you know very
uh inconsistent but when he plays well
he's Unstoppable like I I've known him
for
about almost a decade now I think in
2014 I was working with him
for the chess Olympian in fact he won a
gold medal
for his individual board yeah board five
so that was very impressive he had nine
out of 10. also in the youth
championships in 2018 that's one of the
best performances ever
um so as uh as he keeps saying he puts a
lot of effort on his chess he's had
several difficult games and this is your
lifetime you actually now lost against
him in classical chess I actually had no
idea how that
you're doing fine yeah I had no idea I
didn't even not played him that many
games but uh
Wesley thank you thank you very much you
still have a game to play tomorrow and
maybe the playoffs after that so we let
you rest yeah we'll see you tomorrow
thank you Wesley good luck tomorrow I
wanted to